[Music]
Great Britain's decision to leave the
European Union the so-called brexit
that's really dominating the news you
read about it all the time now naturally
my writing staffs been coming up with a
lot of jokes about the brexit way way
way too many jokes for me to actually do
but I paid for them I paid good money
for them and I don't want him to go to
way so I thought it was a perfect
opportunity to introduce the latest in
rapid-fire brexit joke-telling
technology his name is Nigel the brexit
bot 3000 a robot that only tells brexit
jokes let's get him out here
my common good to see a Nigel yeah so
Nigel what do you think about the brexit
hey how about that brexit huh I haven't
seen this many Brits pull out since
Madonna was dating hey that wasn't very
good I guess this is the worst thing to
happen to England since Simon Cowell was
born Wow last time this many Brits
walked out they were showing paul blart
mall cop - okay
the Praxis will make prices go up in
britain so it will cost them twice as
much to not go to the dentist oh no no
that's pretty low hanging fruit pass the
sweetest kind of fruit okay hey British
people have you noticed if you're poor
and you sleep with your family it is
incest but if you're rich and you in
breed its royalty hey now I don't want
to save the British art in bread but
their family tree is a wreath you're not
on fire these aren't that good hey check
out the guy who wanted the Brits to
leave the EU I have a photo where are
you going oh you've got props now okay
that's fantastic check him out that's
conservative politician Boris Johnson
yeah what I told drink of gravy
boom more like game of scones am i right
he looks like Donald Trump if he drowned
okay that's pretty good that's pretty
good there I know get out there that's
it out I have Maury you guys like
impression no don't do impressions my
impression thank you're too kind
this is my impression of Stephen Hawking
saying hello hello I'm Stephen Hawking I
didn't like that your wait staff no
there's no wait staff oh my impression
of Al Pacino on a toilet what's that
have to do with the brexit ha ha closer
oh that was a chuckle huh okay what else
no that's enough you don't have to do
any more anyone here dating man you've
got to eat robots here now there is
haven't you seen an Oprah act in a movie
okay that's fine we gotta go target to
pander to the crowd excuse me okay now
you're leaving no no no no no no this is
taking
[Music]
[Applause]
our troops left our troops here you yeah
Nigel the brexit bought three thousand
really get out
[Applause]
you